good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Friday Friday
gotta get down on Friday everybody's
lookin forward to though we gank you
botch her great work that was the
harmony at the end I guess but
everyone's looking forward to a weekend
of doing the same thing that they do
every day this week except that now that
we're so deeply ingrained into
quarantine like my days and my weekends
like are very different you know I
actually don't like the weekends like I
love them
I find myself most on normal quarantine
weeks like most at peace with what's
going on during the week but during the
weekend there's so much nothingness that
it actually freaks me out
I love the weekends and it also makes me
appreciate the toast so much like on a
Monday we're so bubbly we're so ready to
talk to y'all on a Thursday were crying
on set oh my god yesterday was such such
a bad day like and it just got worse
from there and I was having such a hard
time identifying what I was feeling
because I felt like emotionally like
really unstable and then like physically
that felt like something was wrong and
then like you know I was freaking out
like thinking I had coronavirus like I
made Ben get me a thermometer took my
temperature 98.7 like perfect and I just
couldn't pinpoint like why I was feeling
so down not that I need to reason but
like it makes you feel better when you
have a reason yeah
when you can just like identify yeah and
this and isolate and that reason like
truly just showed itself you know right
before bed last night I got my period
and not only I didn't even feel better
physically but I just felt so much
better like knowing why I felt so weird
all day yeah and like all my symptoms
made sense I totally forgotten and what
was so funny is when this whole
quarantine started I had just finished
my period and when people were stocking
up on supplies and like everyone's being
nuts but just in case I heard they're
gonna run out of tampons let me get some
tampons and now this is like when I'm
using this box of tampons and I really
thought they were gonna be so
unnecessary but I'm so glad I have them
yeah so I'm feeling a lot better I
didn't really do anything like
proactively yesterday to make myself
feel better in any way yeah and I gave
you some really good suggestions you did
but I literally just from the time it I
got home from the toes I literally
walked home and like with tears in my
eyes
got in bed like tried to explain to Ben
like what was going on he went and got
me a thermometer
we took my temperature I was fine I
didn't even turn my on my TV I literally
laid in bed like watching tick tock
still seven o'clock till it was time for
dinner
damn well I'm glad you're feeling better
you know what I did yesterday that would
make anyone feel better and that I would
recommend that you do like next time
you're feeling down well I did a peloton
ride lizzo themed it was sickening by
the way don't yank my young no yep me
I'm not using [ __ ] on the show all the
time don't yell my I'm not looking your
Young's at all but why don't you try it
the next time like I'm good but maybe
I'll listen to Liz oh yeah it was it was
just really inspiring and it was fun
there's only 30 minutes and it was a
really nice thing to do if you guys had
the Palatine bike or the app you should
try it because it was very uplifting
uplifting I got an email today like one
week on peloton because you made me a
user account profile whatever a week ago
when I decided to do what yoga class
which was a huge mistake and they're
like senior progress like literally one
workout but I try to finish she tried to
make it so optimistic they're like
you're one week strong when it's like
you did one minute of one day I wanna be
is literally like 13 minutes strong yeah
but it's something you know I appreciate
their positive attitude in the time
where I'm really like they're not like
get your fat ass back on the bike you
know they come at it from only from a
positive place not like a shameful
negative place yeah which it's really
easy to do and honestly they're both
effective you know I just think the
negative is like a little bit more
effective but um I agree like I'm
constantly yucking people's positive
attitudes because I'm so negative like
generally I'm negative and that's my
brand but now it's at a point where it's
like a decided like it's a slippery
slope
I know and I had a really big pit
yesterday like aside from just getting
like [ __ ] excuse me I just hate like not
giving a good show you know like that
makes me that we literally have one job
for like the most important part of our
jobs is one hour a day like I just
genuinely couldn't do it yesterday and
then I had a whole pit like thinking I'm
like oh I'm gonna say something really
funny tomorrow you know yeah it's just a
terrible feeling it's a terrible feeling
that I actually think yesterday's
episode was really funny because it was
the two year anniversary and everyone
was sharing like the cutest anecdotes
all day yesterday about how they
discovered the toast what the toast has
meant to them and it was just like a
really good day for the community yeah
that's why I was on my phone and I would
hope that that would have left you to
your spirit yeah so I didn't even feel
the need to watch TV because I literally
was just like reading people's comments
all day like both good and bad but um
yeah it was good it was good it's fine
you know it's like this is like one of
those days like that's just what you get
in quarantine yeah for me those days
happen more on the weekends even though
I enjoy the weekends and just like so
much more in my feelings because I don't
have like the toast to like put a mask
on and because when I'm not wearing
makeup on the weekends like I'm more
inclined to cry versus when I'm wearing
makeup from the toes Jaggi we are the
mask singers here yeah we are the mask
singers but the mask is good like them
it just said it's like you know just you
keep putting one foot in front of the
other eventually you'll get somewhere
fake a chilly me you know no you can
only do that for so long but it's good
Juden do you notice anything different
about me - yes you are wearing a winged
eyeliner made of eyeshadow oh my god yes
oh my god thank you for noticing I just
like really wanted to change it up and I
have to makeup looks like eyeliner and
no eyeliner it's the same base it's the
same everything else but and I love the
way I look with eyeliner but I just feel
like if I wear it every day then it's
not special angry and then it's like if
I'm wearing it to someone's wedding I'm
wearing my toast makeup to someone's
wedding but I mean I just wanted to look
like Bella Hadid today and I decided
like somewhere in between my two makeup
looks was like a nice wing made out of
like a shadow and I used like this weird
pencil and it took me forever and it's
not it's not my best I'm not at any
place where I could like make a tutorial
yet but I'm just feeling good about
looking different yeah I think it's
great I mean Bella Hadid has been
awfully quiet since you showed up today
that's what I'm sad my favorite tik-tok
comment the first time someone left that
comment on my profile I thought it was
like a revolutionary comment when I was
singing the climb and they were like
Miley Cyrus has been weirdly quiet since
this and I was like you guys are
hilarious
no someone comes in on mine like when I
did a dancer like Charlie isn't posted
since you did the Beyonce thing it's
honestly just such a funny comment
there's a new tick tock like verbiage
and just like behaviors yeah they're
coming about and I'm really excited to
be a part of it it was really funny and
the first time it happened to me I just
thought I was special make sure you're
following both of us on tick tock at
girl with no job at Jackie O I go
through like weeks where I post like
five talks and then I don't talk for a
week um but you know I'm just I'm just
keeping it real that's the thing about
being a talker you have no choice but to
keep it real also I watched a new
episode of Punk'd on kwibi and they
punked Addison Rae and I was so excited
except LaChance the rapper is the host
and he pranks everyone but they had the
other members of the high pass like take
over for chance like chance was out that
day okay and I just like I was looking
forward to chance and ad
not Addison and like her loser friends
right so which members have the hype
house now that we know that good ones
well the girls are cool and the boys are
losers so it was that couple you were
telling about Corriveau and muchacho ok
we're in there and then I'm clear and
how I feel about that oh I am very you
know what I'm gonna not be negative but
I'm not they're just not for you they're
offering me and then the Lopez brothers
who like I really liked and now I can't
stand yeah that's fair um but you know
tick tock is like such an easy place to
like watch and hate people you know I
think that maybe is why I'm drawn to it
as a platform as a negative person so
you know yeah I could see that I just
like watch these videos I'm like your
house is ugly your faces people do it
like Larry the worst answer and I don't
bother to clean my room like I'm kicking
Thea while I'm trying to dance but maybe
that's why it's my favorite platform
it's like you know how sometimes like
you sit outside at a restaurant you
people watch ya know what an ugly scarf
like I literally do that on tick-tock
I'm like it'll clean your bedroom yeah
that's hilarious
I never people watch I know there's
other people's hobbies but it's just
like I'm so in my own head I just never
people watch I just rather like scroll
on my phone yeah oh yeah exactly
also quick announcement about our merch
drop for small you have until Sunday the
store closes on Sunday so you have two
more days to place your orders
then we decided to do a little bit of a
giveaway it's in our private Facebook
group so if you listen to this podcast
or you watch a video and you're not in
our group our group is called the
morning toasters you just got to answer
some questions to get in and we are
giving away a bunch of $100 gift card so
you can get yourself some merch I know a
lot of people couldn't get merch this
time around for one reason or another
and we wanted to make sure that everyone
could so they're supposed to in the main
group called the morning toasters drop a
comment why do you want to win or you
can nominate someone who should win the
gift cards and get yourself some merch
before Sunday well close the contest
later tonight totally this is part of
the new merch shop this little crop tea
that I'm loving I wore it last week um
being an outfit repeater with some of
these off it is stellar
is it I mean because these trousers are
just like hilarious and they're the
perfect shade of purple right I came up
with this outfit I was laying in bed
last night because I was like I want to
wear some of the new merch but I've been
wearing it everyday and then I was like
but I can switch it up so I have a whole
new outfit that is actually so crazy I
genuinely thought of this outfit in bed
last night as well Wow
yeah cuz I was like I'm done wearing
leggings like I'm done having
a warm vagina like I'm just over it and
this is like my nicest pair of
sweatpants these are wild fox they were
like expensive so I'm like how can i
stile and I really wanted to wear toes
merch but the shirt I was gonna wear a
little Ward this week I can't repeat the
same week so this is my favorite piece
of toast March and it's in the store but
not right now
yeah the cross to bear all the old merch
will be coming back once the spring
merch orders are placed I actually made
a commitment to myself that I'm from now
on I'm only going to be wearing toes
March on the show there's just nothing
else to wear I know you know I told you
of my plight that I gave away all my
toes merch like trying to be so cool
like you want some right branding so
annoying but we have a toast closet here
that I'll have to dive into yeah she's
gotta get your hands in that Theo is
good precious thank you for asking I
heard a rumor that he's been loving his
love sack can you confirm or deny what
is the official statement from the
soccer camp for the first time in
probably two years
Theo did not sleep in our bed last night
and then they saw if Ben I mean if Theo
like goes into his crate to go to sleep
Ben will pull him out Ben loves to sleep
with him but also complains about how
annoying he is like he literally sleeps
on Ben's dick like it's so annoying for
men but I don't mind it and last night
we both both made the decision to like
leave him let him get a sound night's
sleep you know in the love sack he came
into bed at about 5:00 in the morning so
he spent the most the night in the sack
and out all night he was out all night
and I was really happy about it like
Theo he's an independent boy and much
like his mother he really understands
the importance of sleep and he knows
that there's a special place in hell for
people who wake up other people which is
probably why he hates his dad so much
please don't DM him and snitch on me
again with everything cool yesterday
yeah he didn't know what I was talking
like he didn't say anything when he got
home which means nobody gm2 him about
the snitch Inge got it well my husband
committed a petty atrocity that I just
wanted to share with the class it's a
new level with a new level so two nights
ago was Seder we had like a dishwasher
full of dishes I fell asleep early after
putting everything in the dishwasher and
when I came home from the toasts
yesterday I went into the kitchen and
and he I guess he had made himself eggs
and his plate and his fork in the hot
pan were in the dishwasher
they were air drying and I was like
what's this and he was like oh I decided
to hand wash it and I know because he
didn't want our dishwasher
he hand washed his plate that
to unload the dishwasher in order to put
in his new plate that's bad but you know
what my husband would have done he would
have put those dishes in the dishwasher
and reran the whole thing yeah that's
great I think I just hoped that like
when it was over I would waltz in wow we
don't have enough dishwasher soap for
those kinds of a time actually right
after this I have to run I'm out of dawn
I'm out of baking soda and I'm also out
of what was I just mentioning that I
needed I think he said he needs to go to
the CBS yeah I also need to get a new
sponge I've been using my sponge more
than ever it's disgusting I've been
thinking about my sponge recently
because in the book that I read they
said that they put the sponge in the
microwave to clean it and I that's
disgusting
no I mean and then I just got me
thinking have you ever cleaned my sponge
but it's one of those things it's like a
bar of soap it's like technically self
clean you know no need to replace it
like once a month it depends how much
you use your sponge until up until three
weeks ago my sponge was never touched
no my sponge has always been like
working here and there like she would go
on vacation but then she would always
come back to work she was like
middle-class sometimes I would say I
could never find her
like she was at my a but then she came
back oh my god I just like I mean what
having one of those days maybe it's
because I was in like such a low
yesterday and I'm like I'm really
feeling so much better I'm just like
loving Theo so much and I love him I say
every day is a god's gift to you I just
can't believe that there are people who
are quarantined without feel like I
judge me yeah I can me you know and like
you're one of the elites because you're
like you have privilege like you get to
see him like once a day but there are
people who just like don't even know the
love of a Pheo and it's so genuinely
like heartbreaking for them I feel RDH
for them ya know I do as well I feel rth
for myself like I use that little Theo
pillow every day it's like what I used
to leave my kindle up when I'm reading
because my wrists are about to fall off
you guys they're hurt so much
it's crazy you're like mr.duval my
carpal tunnel came back [ __ ] Carl came
back I need to get a wrist you need to
get them or just one of those things
like not a cast but like it's something
that straightens it so you don't move it
as much yeah I don't know or I just need
to like bring a phone stand into bed
yeah I need to figure it out cuz it's
it's no bueno no it's not you actually
recommended that I read Jessica
Simpson's book yesterday and
you told me that like I intended to take
the advice but you know life just had
other plans there was no way in hell you
were gonna do it but I know it's like
late sings how the quarantine is like
I'm ready like over a month in but I do
want to read that book and I do want to
read the lady gang book because you said
it was like really easy to read and so
good it was so nice to get to know them
I feel like I've always had so many
questions about each of them and like
just at various points in their life and
it was full of answers so I'm thinking
about it you know I'm definitely gonna
do it it's just a matter it's not a
matter of if it's a matter of when okay
well I like that bu I can't believe that
we're going on we're three days from now
by the time we come back on the toast we
will be have been in quarantine for one
whole month so we're going into our
fifth week is that where you're sort of
going into our fifth week yes and we
started quarantining on March 13th and
today is April 10th like that's crazy no
it's it's awful it's really awful like I
can't I know everyone out there is
feeling what we're feeling and it's like
even just the being in the housing but
like the like 16 million people don't
have jobs I know it's there it's like I
don't know what the saddest part of this
whole thing is is it the old people who
are literally being forced to die alone
is it the entire workforce that has been
laid off is it the economy like what is
it it's all so so sad it's so sad and
this has been an extra sad week like
especially for New York New York has
more cases than any country in the world
yesterday almost 800 people died in New
York and it was the highest record of
people who've ever died in one day
that's crazy but like things are getting
better yeah because like the deaths come
like weeks after you know it's all sort
of staggered yeah it's like just
communities being fun but it's like this
is when it's bad yeah well we're here to
brighten everyone's day hopefully forget
a little bit about what's going on in
the world and give you the Fast Five
story is that you need to know before
you wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast out of your morning matzah
that's true you guys but it's been a
minute since we've spoken about Sanford
and I feel RDH I would feel RDH if I
didn't let you guys know that sometimes
adding one final piece can bring your
whole ensemble together and that
finishing touch can be your perfume
fragrances can last can create lasting
impressions because smell is so closely
linked with memories so true every time
I smell trouble I think about the time I
throw up on Montauk Highway if you're
ready to make a lasting impression
Sanford can help you deliver your
signature scent or keep things fresh
with new
fragrances from brands including Dolce
and Gabanna Tom Ford Versace and more
Sanford is a luxury fragrance
subscription service with over 600
designer brands just choose the
fragrance you want to try and they'll
send you a 30 day supply in a travel
friendly refillable case to help you
find the perfect scent you can sort
their extensive collection by brand
occasion season and more plus they now
carry products from other categories
like skincare wellness and makeup from
brands like Aparri glam glow glow recipe
tart and many more Jackie and I have
been subscribers of Sanford since they
first started sponsoring the toast like
well over a year ago and it's fabulous I
am now into like this mountain goats
moment which is just making me feel like
a refreshed you know real housewife in
the Hamptons it's fabulous and I never
would have known about it if it weren't
for some bird Sanford is so fabulous
it's great for like a girl on the go
which none of us all right now but it's
also great for quarantine because it's
the easiest quickest way to make
yourself feel like a little fancy and a
little cute and like a little clean it's
like get a new perfume from Sanford try
it out give yourself a little spritz
you'll be feeling like a whole new woman
or man he have your quarantine with your
significant other like a spritz is
sometimes so necessary which can go a
long way get 30% off your first one
today that's only $10 for your first
fragrance go to scent bird dot-com slash
steen and use our promo code Steen for
30% off your first month
again that's SC ent BIR decom slash teen
to sign up and use our promo code Steen
ste and that means your first perfume or
cologne is just $10 sion smell amazing
also we want to wish a good good friday
to all of the toasters out there who are
celebrating today oh my god it's Good
Friday so that is when Jesus came back
yes and everything was good on the
Friday learn Christmas is Jesus's
birthday
mm-hmm Easter is uh when he has Razak he
has risen yeah but like when did he die
Good Friday and then Easter he comes
back I'm unclear I'm clear as well here
I'm unfamiliar but um welcome back happy
Good Friday that was so cool of him you
know just like I'm making appearance
very like when you tied the pregame you
show up at the club you know 100% love
that um and Easter is this weekend I
hope everyone is finding ways to
celebrate in self-isolation oh yeah I
guess that's why I've been seeing so
many chick talk so like how to dye your
eggs I haven't seen one we have
completely different yeah
I get a lot of crafts cuz I'm like kind
of artsy also they're using like eggs
from the store am I mistaken in that
Easter eggs are like chickens like
they're eggs from the store but so are
you supposed to eat them
no they're just decorative they're
symbolic kind of like Passover yeah I
guess very similar but I think maybe you
probably like hard-boil them so they
don't start like cracking on you I mean
you can't paint them with our hard
boiled you have to get the shell
interesting but I'm just curious about
like the kids who are like are doing the
Easter Bunny hunt in the yard are they
picking up chicken like raw egg I'm not
sure but Good Friday is when Jesus died
so it's actually not a happy day so I
won't wish you a good Good Friday but I
will wish you a meaningful Good Friday
right and then Easter's when you
celebrate his big return he has risen
very exciting I you know a few one year
ago I went to an Easter party with you
know some of my friends and I took a
beautiful photo of myself like literally
I was like mmm this was last year last
year I was looking so fabulous I just
got a new haircut and the haircut was
really like highlighted in this photo
and I made my caption she has risen
because I was on an elevated surface
someone like literally picked me up and
put me on the mantle I was really skinny
back then and I got so many hateful
comments like I guess I can understand
why it was like offensive but like
sometimes like it was just a good
caption you know and like I was saying
to change it and I was just upset
because like my new caption was not
nearly as clever as my what was your new
caption like makes Easter about herself
like not even funny
and people were still giving me [ __ ] for
that one you know I mean but I respect
her religion I do I just I was like
genuinely like in love with that caption
I thought yes so funny and honestly I
saw a lot of other people use that
caption I mostly like Miley Cyrus and it
was fine for her so why isn't it fine
for you well because I read two comments
out of like every totally by the way the
eggs are hard-boiled and you do eat them
on Easter so like they're not just
decorative and symbolic oh wow so you've
learned so much it's crazy what you like
the ideas that you have about like other
people's holidays and then like when you
take the time to learn about it like I
was actually just explaining a stator
plate to someone and and matzah and it's
like she's probably heard of matzah but
like doesn't understand about the
unleavened bread I'm like and don't have
any bread on the table but she might not
have realized that that was like why you
have the matzah yeah and it's like when
I think of traditions of
the religions verse mind like mine since
it seems so complicated like a pageant I
know like a shank bone like I got to
explain a shank bone first is like an
egg you know like it's just I feel are
silly different oh my god her oset don't
get me started
oh my god said that [ __ ] Oh said is
delicious it's not my favorite but or
like the bitter herbs you know I'm just
that so easy for the bitter time right
but there are some that are in the salt
water the tears
oh yes the tears of our ancestors unless
we not forget yeah it's just a lot and I
feel like Judaism like just does
everything so extra like there's like
every leaf is like you know so now
people are saying they don't eat the
eggs I don't know okay but maybe their
heart you guys I'm sorry like I can't I
also think like for kids they used like
those plastic eggs like you get like a
ring in when you pay a quarter that's a
chocolate in there I feel like you do
also like paint eggs DIY and then do you
eat the egg no all I'm saying is that
like I had a religious Easter experience
a few years ago when we were in Florida
and there was like this big fancy brunch
at our hotel for Easter and like we
weren't necessarily participating in
Easter but we do participate in brunch
and ariana grande was there this was
like way before she was a star do you
remember that yes that was so random
that was so random
okay some people eat their eggs others
people don't and the two are at war in
the content oh ok god I got it oh that
is what I'm getting that's what we do
here at the morning toast we start
religious conversations yeah that's what
we do okay this is the morning Christ
are you ready this is the morning egg
are you ready for our first story hmm
you don't look ready it's an interesting
question yeah I'm ready but you're about
to be prosecutors release rowing photos
Lorie Lachlan allegedly used to get her
daughters into USC okay this is a big
story of the day I think it'd still be a
big story even if there was other news
going on because these photos have been
spoken about so much yes we have now
gotten the photos of Olivia Jade and her
sister Isabella on their Frank Underwood
style
rowing machine that you know showed us
see their talent did rowing prowess so
um this particular photo
I know upset a lot of people but for me
it was really really personally
triggering because um a few years ago I
made like the really big mistake to buy
a pack of twelve personal training
sessions at Equinox and I had this
trainer his name was Mark and he was
blond and he was like handsome and like
insta
graeme and Logano say just felt
something secure and the first day like
I didn't really know what I was in for
and I had eaten a bullet honey nut
cheerios right before the session and we
started out the session he's like let's
do ten minutes on the rowing machine I
had never even seen a rowing machine
before I didn't know like it was a
machine like this before a house of
cards came out yeah and I don't watch
house of cards I'm just like what like
what like I've heard of an elliptical
like I've heard of the classics I see
the newer line it's just so specific you
know and he made me do it for 10 minutes
and I literally look to him I'm like
mark I gotta go and I went to the
bathroom and threw up all my honey nut
cheerios oh my god Wow yes so I guess
you haven't been on month in no like
this photo is just like bringing back
all those negative memories keeping the
taste of honey nut cheerios I mean I've
been having terrible heartburn all day
and I think it's because I saw that
photo that's right well anyways people
are obviously going in on the photos a
lot like Olivier Jade's form is much
better than her sister Isabella's tums
that's what I needed at CBS got it for
the heartburn and so the saga continues
I mean to be honest this is gonna be a
controversial thing to say but he just
really don't care you know like this was
a really big deal like a year over a
year ago now it's just like the world is
so much different now than it was back
then and I know I know there's so much
wrong with that whole thing and I get it
like I get to print like I really really
do like I get the corruption of the
wealthy I totally got it but like right
now I just I don't really care I
completely and to be honest like I'm
kind of mad at this whole scandal
because it is cause Felicity Huffman to
be left out of the desperate housewives
reunion did you hear about it I heard
there's a reunion but it's really just
like another virtual zoom happy hour
whatever miglin odd a desperate
housewives reunion Nicollette Sheridan
and Teri Hatcher are both not
participating because if you're real
desperate housewives fan you know that
they were both very controversial on set
we really thought that they were the
stars and distance themselves from the
entire group so no one is really spoken
to them and of course Felicity Huffman
will not be participating because she is
formerly incarcerated and she's just
dealing with that so what's the
desperate housewives reunion with out
Lynette Scavo
I agree nothing of the sort and to me
like I hold Annette Scavo so dear to my
heart similar to like a place where I
hold Miranda Hobbes because I consider
them to be one in the same like when you
watch the kid as the show as a kid you
were like and when that's ugly like you
were just like you know what I mean like
you would
Miranda cuz she like more weird things
and like you hated Lynette because she
was like always complaining yelling at
Tom but then you grow up and you're like
damn these were the only women on the
show with like real jobs real head on
their shoulders like real moral
compasses of the show like and so I I
feel very like a very strong deep and um
empowering connection with one Lynette
Scavo yeah and honestly Tom was an idiot
like I just I I was on the plane once we
need to rewatch I think it's we're
coming up on time like it's been a year
I don't know I don't know how long
quarantine is gonna go on like I'm
really hoping that the end of this month
is the end of it and but even when we go
back to normalize like life is never
gonna be normal again you know and if
anyone ever tries to shake my hand
that's the thing about me this will be
me too cool oh oh my god it's a thing of
the past it's a thing of the past and
you know a goodbye and good riddance the
fact that I would ever touch your hand
and then touch my face or eat my food
like I don't know you know the fact that
i just used to like believe my house
come home and not wash my hands is crazy
no the fact that people would like take
the subway take a cab take a bus come
home go to work eat their breakfast whoo
I mean there's still people who kiss on
the subway and that's always been
disgusting it's just common sense
you know agreed well I'm back to Gasper
now so he's really quickly I was on a
plane once and I was so bored like the
time was just not moving and there is a
obviously a Facebook subgroup
Jesper toast arrives people who love
Desperate Housewives and I wrote a post
like tell me who your least favorite
character is and why and literally
everyone's least favorite character with
Tom Scavo and I was just i litter is on
the plane I was being so annoying like
people kept looking at me I couldn't
breathe honestly my least favorite
character was Susan media really she was
a big big big time she is the Carrie
Bradshaw well yeah no you have to think
about it like I'm the four protagonists
you can even include 85 like who's your
least favorite and then sub husbands
other people other neighbors I can't
sure no it was still Susan yeah my
favorite I'm like subhuman it was Carlos
oh I had a thing yeah I loved him yeah
good time but you don't makes you really
depressed I'm doing this with one tree
hill too is looking at their Instagram
yeah especially like I can't do it right
not like
eva longoria she's still a megastar but
like just random people from these shows
who like we're so important and like big
in your life when you were watching and
now like Carlos with his 60 doesn't
Instagram followers like it's just it's
so sad but like Carlos is a member
Instagram like that's okay that's fine
by me
I guess yeah okay anyways that's the
latest on operation varsity blues but as
you said very I completely agree it's
just not on my radar right now I'm just
I can't my plate is full
yeah my baby's looking a lot like my
plate is full yeah my play this full of
like things I need to be negative about
you know and this is not one of them
like I genuinely don't care and I just
wanted like in a time where people are
needing more content than ever I wish we
would stop talking about this so Olivia
trade can make me a few more YouTube
videos like this little thing I did on
my eyes was inspired by Olivia Jenny
video then I saw a few months so yeah
now after this she probably will go
quiet again you know she was talking a
lot with her since yeah things like slow
down yeah but I think things are gonna
cup next story some exciting interesting
news SNL is returning to air with
original content this weekend
it's over zoom I thought it's unclear
how they're doing it it's not
necessarily zoom okay
the creators of SNL have announced that
the sketch show will return with fresh
material this weekend deadline reports
despite social distancing orders due to
the current a virus pandemic
exactly how producer Lauren Michaels the
show's 17 cast members and dozens of
crew members plan to pull this off has
yet to be revealed they have confirmed
the new episode will indeed be broadcast
from remote locations including Weekend
Update hosted by Colin Jost and Michael
che
I'm mostly excited about this one
because its content - I am really
interested to hear from Michael che I've
been thinking about him a lot really
I've really just been like my heart goes
out to him and I want to hear from him
and I feel like this could actually be
premium content well yeah we can update
is a sketch that I could see being done
like literally from anywhere but I'm not
so much like you know excited about like
The Bachelor sketch from someone's
apartment I know but maybe like they're
all kind of being tasked to do like solo
sketches or something or maybe they came
back in in his home with like whoever
she's isolating with it and she's
putting together a sketch for like her
and her quarantine buddies it's
interesting is there a musical guest
do they need one everything now is a
musical cuz I don't that's actually the
last thing I want is another from home
concert it'll be this will be
interesting you know SNL in my opinion
like and in the opinion of most people
it's supposed to be like this height of
comedic genius and honestly the bar is
high for them normally and if they make
this like into some shitty little Skype
like I'm gonna be pissed yeah or maybe
maybe they're braving it maybe of some
of them are going to the studio maybe
they're filming with like a bit like a
skeleton no studio audience no studio
audience maybe not even all the cast
members just like the big ones maybe
they've been having like groups of the
cast quarantined together no I don't
think so because like that sounds like
torture big time with your coworkers but
I feel like maybe if everyone's wearing
masks and everyone's being protected
maybe they're going to the studio it's
just so funny because the last time SNL
was live they had that corona the party
a sketch yeah and that like soap opera
where like they're quarantined oh yeah
yeah yeah it's just funny like how much
has changed that is funny but also like
other shows like news programs are still
filming in studios so yeah you know I
think it's not that crazy to think that
they might go to the studio I mean look
at us look at us and we're being super
careful maybe they're just like but
they're just so many but they're just
like Oh morning hosts can do it we can
do it but maybe they're half the amount
of people yeah maybe they're operating
like New York State is saying 25 percent
yeah I mean it's definitely fair to say
that we are inspiring others yeah and
like that's all we're here to do and I
wouldn't protest okay next up a little
blast from the past news is it blasts
from the past news that's brought to you
by noon because if it's not I'm really
not it no no it is getting in shape
doesn't have to be about losing a
specific amount of weight or a magic
number on the scale it's about building
healthier habits and feeling better
about yourself if fitting into your
favorite pair of jeans is your goal
great but there are many reasons why you
might want to practice self-care and
every person is different because we're
all different
NUMA just to your lifestyle they teach
you the psychology behind the decisions
you make and then they help you keep
track of everything from workouts steps
analyzing your diet and recommending
healthy recipes new also connects you
with personally assigned goal
specialists and a community of numerous
so you have the support you need to
empower your change
you can practice better self-care feel
more confident in your clothes have more
energy to just give yourself an overall
glow it's easy and convenient and their
their entire app and program
it's super easy to use they have
specific lessons about psychology where
you can log your food and it's super
flexible you can eat how you can eat
what you want in moderation because they
help you control your habits it is a
habit changing solution that helps users
develop a new relationship with food
through personalized courses it is not a
diet it is a healthy and easy to stick
to way of life where no food is
considered good bad or off-limits Noom
teaches you moderation and B can be used
in conjunction with preexisting popular
diets if you want nobody tells you what
to do and what not to do it teaches you
how to look inside your own mind and
make better decisions for yourself we're
all strapped for time so numa's just
asking you to commit to 10 minutes a day
for yourself you're human so if you go
off track there's no shaming just Hill
hip tips to help you get back on track
tomorrow you don't have to change it all
in one day small steps make big progress
sign up for your trial today at noon and
oom dot-com slash toast what do you have
to lose visit new mom slash toast to
start your trial today that's Noom comm
slash toast sign on B well I'm sorry
what was up last from the nest class
from the past news so the Cheetah Girls
are taking into him live and they're
squashing some beef what's the beef
there's major beef between Keely
Williams and Adrienne Bailon Houghton
Keely Williams was the girl from TLC and
yeah and she was in movies 1 & 2 but she
was not in movie 3 she wasn't yes
so Kelly Williams and Raven Symone are
using their quarantine time to make
amends the former Cheetah Girls members
hopped on Instagram Live this week to
talk about their childhood drama and
kilise recent public feud with fellow
Cheetah Girl Adrienne Bailon quote
because of you I get to talk to you and
heal a wound from that time period when
we were younger that I probably wouldn't
get to do if I didn't understand that
you know what you like to shake [ __ ] up
she said Raven said to Kili yeah I'm a
firestarter for sure it's an acquired
taste
Keeley then asked Raven why she sorry
Raven didn't participate hold up Keeley
then asked Raven why she didn't
participate in the group's third film in
2008 the Cheetah Girls one world Oh
Raven did it Raven I don't remember that
and where does the other where's the
blonde girl come in fillory so we're
there for Cheetah Girls yeah okay yeah
and there was Adrienne Bailon Raven fake
hillary duff and girl from TLC chasing
waterfalls and then in in the last movie
there was just no raven i guess maybe
that's why I don't
like remember it because I maybe didn't
watch it I was a raven stan gelman yeah
she got a little out of control but oh
yeah but you know what she was a
talented star and like she's entitled
yeah I know as I I get that feeling you
know feeling like you're just more
talented vocally than the people around
you
Raven said the cliquish way that there
was during that movie made me feel
excluded from my original team not that
it was strong to begin with but I felt
excluded we have other things that just
led up to that moment that were just
weird personal outside of business Kili
apologized to her even saying I would
never try to hurt you on purpose and
Raven accepted that apology saying well
I appreciate that sweetheart and I
release any pain towards you that I have
and I cancel clear and delete it Wow
funny I like loved Raven Symone I just
watched her Justin Bieber's veteran live
and it was like so awkward and funny and
I really liked it but I don't think
there's anyone who's had a weirder
career than Raven like she got so famous
from that's or even like she was like a
star and then she like was so quiet and
controversial and then she went on the
view and then she went back to Disney
Channel like I guess I know why she was
on the bull-type - she was yes she's
placed like this influencers oh and then
she had a very brief but you know
impactful um
movie career College road trip that was
in theaters it's like she was she was
well on her way and then she just
decided to stop yeah and then she was
quiet and then she went on the view
which I thought is like the bravest
thing that anyone can do I just feel
like she's seen some stuff like yeah
have you ever seen that video of her
doing that I'm Raven Symone you're
watching Disney Channel thing oh the a
while back some of the footage from when
the Disney Channel stars used to do that
like the long footage of her doing and
over and over again was released and she
looks so miserable and so annoyed and
it's like I just feel like she she saw
some stuff yeah and I think in that
lifestyle like some of those kids are
made for that life like they just want
to like be Dance Moms there's just like
machines
yeah and Raven I feel like has a good
head or hat or still whatever has a good
head on her shoulders and like she was
just above that but she became so famous
yeah I used to love that so Raven so
much no it's it's so good it's so
[ __ ] good and anyways Adrienne Bailon
and Kili also had beef that they were
talking about wit season Galleria wasn't
the problem Kili was
she's beefing with everyone yeah I don't
know KIAC said that her main issue with
Adrienne was quote she didn't come to my
dad's funeral or call me when he died
I'm sorry I'm not trying to be messy I'm
being real with you I'm snow I'm sorry I
love you I swear to God no come on you
can say what you want about me and how
you thoughts about me but you can't ever
say that I didn't ride for Adrienne you
can't say that I didn't do anything
and what did Adrienne have to say to
that she wasn't on the live so now like
the malls in Adrienne's court and I just
feel like Adrienne is on another level
like she has left the Cheetah Girls in
the dust
she loved the Cheetah Girls in the dust
and she like temporarily like you know I
had a parking spot at the Kardashian
Plaza right and you know and she opted
out yeah and now she's like a very well
respected host and as hosts ourselves we
have no choice but to respect her
decision yeah no I I really I love her
and her marriage is like so cute and her
husband's like this guy named Israel and
I just like think that they're so cute
they're so cute
except like a part of me will show a
ship her and Robin like yeah she could
have been I guess you can't link really
save anyone but I feel like if anyone
could have saved anyone Adrienne could
have saved Rob well I mean they were
together before he like really needed
saving and I think a lot of his you know
need to be saved had to do with the fact
that like the woman I was like his
dreams like and they were so perfect yet
he's the one that got away
yeah like that a whole episode where
they pretended like he slapped her like
that was so they were just perfect for
each other
yeah we're gonna recap Keeping Up with
the Kardashians and Real Housewives of
New York at the end of this episode you
can't believe how much I like forgot
about the history of the Cheetah Girls
even forgetting that Raven wasn't in the
30 and I feel as though I need to now go
watch all the Cheetah Girls movies yeah
because to me the last yes but to me the
last movie is when they sing that song
weak like we go all around the world we
go the last me to me when they're no
that's the second because Galleria is in
that okay Sanjay like one world I think
there's a movie where like gallery no no
where the other girls like get a record
deal without Raven and they make them
sound terrible and they sing that song
we can go around the way when you go on
the grounds Brown where we stop nobody
knows but we don't care just man here we
go so I think that's the last movie and
like Adrienne Bailon like takes on the
role of the protagonist when to be
honest she just wasn't made for it yeah
but maybe she was maybe we were looking
it through the lens of like Raven stands
but now there were
green sands will be like Oh finally her
come up in no I'm I must I'm a raven
Stan I think that next week Monday toast
movie of the day should be treated girls
one Tuesday cheetah girls to Wednesday
cheetah girls three I just I have a
feeling and maybe because I went back
and watched so many D calms like they
genuinely do not age well or Monday
descendants one Tuesday to seven minutes
you know and say descendants we know I'm
an adult I won't watch Confessions of a
Teenage Drama Queen okay okay are you
ready for our next story sure cuz
tick-tock star Charlie D'Amelio says she
and her family are interested in doing a
reality show well I'm shocked in a
recent interview with Entertainment
Tonight the fifteen-year-old social
media star opened up about her family's
thoughts on starting a reality show
quote I mean definitely something that
would be super fun she said she shared
that a reality series would be a way for
her fans to quote see what goes on when
we're not just posting tick-tocks
I feel like no one really gets to see
but people are always talking about how
they think our family dynamic is pretty
cool I was like into this idea until I
read these quotes yeah you know Charlie
gives me a Pitt because and by that this
is just total conjecture because I like
love her and follow her but we're
talking about girls who were made for
this life and girls who aren't made for
this life and I feel like Charlie's like
not made for the life like I don't feel
like she like loves being famous I think
that like all this happened for and
she's obviously running with it
especially because her parents
encouraged it so much but I just feel
like she's not one of those kids like I
feel like Addison is like made for this
life like running around that way being
an influencer and I just feel like
Charlie um oh and all the people around
charlie like make her think that like
this is what she wants about they I
don't know her at all I'm just like
totally guessing but like I like have a
pit for her sometimes I when she was on
Jimmy Fallon she was just like so quiet
I hear what you're saying about how you
feel that Charlie's this way and Addison
is that way but I feel like sometimes
it's when people are most resistant to
like fame or whatever responsibility
that they carry it's when they're able
to like actually be the best at what
they're doing like when you think about
the royal family and how like even like
Queen Elizabeth and her sister Princess
Margaret like Princess Margaret wanted
to be a queen like she was ready for the
spotlight she was ready for all that and
Queen and Queen Elizabeth was even like
said to her private sector secretary I
was like is there any way I could step
down and like Margaret could be the
Queen when they were younger like cuz
she just had the personality for it but
like Margaret would have been a terrible
Queen because she was so out there and
like I mean there's a difference between
being a queen and being a famous person
but I think the fact that Charlie is
more reserved will allow her to keep
head on her shoulders oh and at the end
of the day like she'll have more
longevity as opposed to someone who's so
excited about it that they might burn
out you know I'm just referring to this
particular article like do I think
Charlie gemelos trying to have a reality
show
no my concern here is that like Charlie
D'Amelio will get a reality show and
like it will show that like there's
nothing much more than the 60 seconds on
tick-tock you know yeah but the family
dynamic is obviously interesting like
they started a tick-tock for their
family like the parents are just like so
honestly thirsty I don't know I just
think that like they're having so much
success in like these new media I would
rather see them do a quiz show yeah
because I think like an hour long like
the traditional reality TV format it's a
lot to carry you have to be so
interesting controversial funny witty
impressive like all of these things and
and you could still not be successful
look at the Lohan's living like em like
you could be so crazy and still not be
successful yeah look you could have dina
Lohan on your show and it's still not
gonna do well yeah makes you think so I
I feel like a short-form
they should six it's actually a great
idea you know and yeah then it also like
to us take that pressure off of like
having your whole life be under a
microscope you'll listen has a podcast I
do apologize if you hear a brief whisper
in the background
it's Theo snoring let's take a listen I
don't apologize because it's the most
beautiful sound of the precious gem
it's so beautiful this should be like
so she a sound on like headspace yeah I
mean literally we were watching One Tree
Hill last night Theo was snoring so loud
we literally had to move him like he was
we were listening at like a level 75
volume and Theo snoring was so loud icon
the way and I wouldn't about it and he
would just angel boy hi my boy I might
need your purchase point angel boy oh I
love you okay ready for a pizza final
story because it's kind of a [ __ ] up
story and I just want to shine light on
it because I couldn't find a fifth story
and it's really [ __ ] up okay
people are luring instacart shoppers
with big tips and then changing them to
zero excuse me people are trying to get
instacart grocery deliveries and you you
select how much tip you want to give
when you place your order okay so the
instacart shoppers are seeing these big
hips obviously prioritizing big tip
orders and then before the order gets
delivered the people at home are
changing the tips to zero are you
[ __ ] kidding me no it's not cool if
you're doing this it's not cool I just
want to say this is a huge problem and I
really blame the platform you shouldn't
be able to change your tip I mean first
of all putting the tip in before you get
your order like what if someone gives
you a bag of duty like that's that
shouldn't be allowed you shouldn't be
allowed to change it but you also
shouldn't be able to do the tip before
though the order is done because maybe
someone does an amazing job and you want
to give them more maybe someone flick
comes to your door and just slaps you in
the face right I don't know it's it's
really like really not cool demand for
grocery delivery is surging amid the
current virus pandemic and many
customers are struggling to get the
items they want or even a time slot for
delivery oh my god I'm so hungry I just
realized I didn't eat like a proper
dinner last night we were just talking
like cooking is cool but I'm over and
over like it's just really exhausting
yeah the dishes I mostly just eat chips
and you know what I love I love Passover
macaroons ooh I hate them love them
they're like a coconut
they're not like a lotta a macaroon no
[ __ ] macaroons I love them when
macaroons became like a big trend like
no DeRay like pastel colored ones and I
had never like tried them before like
why do people love macaroons been eating
those since I was a kid they're [ __ ]
disgusting
I hate its hassle my macaroon it's weird
that Passover macaroons are called
macaroons yeah there's like Mac at home
my comm hole yeah
anyway some people are dealing with that
by offering big tips such as $50 or more
to entice instacart workers to pick up
their orders but some of those people
have turned the tactic into a bait and
switch
offering up the big tip and then taking
it away as soon as the person who risks
their health to get them their groceries
has made the delivery if you or someone
you know have done this just know that I
think you are literally the most
disgusting piece of [ __ ] subhuman
[ __ ] like I literally hope terrible
things happen to you that's awful like I
feel like I've been going out of my way
to like do oh and I actually wanted to
share to do like nice things for
essential workers like in my building
like my entire building is still staffed
fully and me and been ordered pizza for
them today like we have a delivery
schedule I thought of it I saw someone
do it on Instagram if you make some in
it I reminded me um because it's just
like little things like the like they
saw have to come every day and risk
their who's their health so like when I
go to the grocery store to like I tip
all the cashiers like that's just what
you have to do yeah and like this is so
me and like I can't get over it because
so many people are working overtime
working more hours than ever and being
paid the same amount yeah and it's the
least we can do to show them our
appreciation and I mean absolutely so
you can do is just be good to your word
and give them the tip that you said you
were gonna give them and if you aren't
gonna give them a tip just be honest all
but you require is honesty yeah and I
guess up if you're someone like who's
done this just realize that it's so
[ __ ] up enough to be like a story in
the past Ivan don't ever do that it's
awful oh my god like I even like let's
say I gave someone like a huge tip
before and they did a terrible job like
in this time and I would still give them
the tip right like and what because you
know you're not gonna get everything
that you want like no thank you for
getting me my groceries oh my god that's
so upsetting like that makes me really
really sad I'm sorry that that's
happening to people yeah let's dive into
our TV recap or we're gonna recap Real
Housewives of New York new episode and
keeping up with the kardashians new
episode both aired last night and the
segment is brought to you by daily
harvest we're all overbooked
overstimulated and constantly running on
empty for us we're always rushing to
make podcast podcast episodes enemy
the obligations different projects would
barely have enough time to eat complete
meals let alone prepare healthy ones
being busy doesn't mean you have to
resort to takeout or overly processed
food that's why we love daily harvest
they deliver the food you want to eat
but don't have the time to make right to
your door
plus if you start your cooking last week
and now you're really over it daily
harvest is even better for people like
us because it is so easy to make they
make easy to eat they make it easy to
eat more fruits and vegetables with
thoughtfully sourced chef crafted foods
that can be prepared in five minutes or
less they work directly with farms to
harvest organic fruits and vegetables at
their peak and then freeze them within
24 hours to lock it with the nutrients
everything stays fresh until you're
ready to enjoy it so especially in the
quarantine time being able to freeze
stuff is so fabulous because you really
truly never know when this is gonna end
and you always need food so being able
to keep stuff in the freezer is fabulous
stuff in the freezer that's fresh and
nutritious and delicious and
superstitious each recipe takes one step
to prepare with room to make them your
own
add your favorite milk to blend up a
smoothie or heat up harvestable and top
it with an avocado or a fried egg
whether you're at home at your desk or
on the go daily harvest is the easiest
way to have a delicious and nutritious
meal or snack go to daily harvest comm
enter the promo code toast to get $25
off your first box that's promo code
toast for $25 off your first box at
daily harvest com
that's daily harvest dot-com Wow let's
start with New York because I watched it
this morning and it's most fresh in my
brain I thought that the first episode
of the season was like kind of a letdown
and even though there wasn't a ton of
drama I thought this was a bet this was
a step in the right direction yeah I'd
like to see all the girls like getting
together right off the bat we're gonna
make it happen we're gonna bond it's
really crazy the way that they're
behaving like so much of it like the
shadow of Bethenny is still there like I
feel like Luanne would have never made
that speech at that dinner if Bethenny
was in the room because it would have
been conceding too much that Bethenny
was right I'm by the way of all the
people in the Housewives fear the person
who deserves that speech the most is
Bethenny right Bethenny was so good to
LuAnn when she was going through all
that stuff and the wind was so in that's
all Bethenny ever wanted to hear is for
her to say that and she would have just
everything just like wreaked of Bethenny
but even Ramona kissing Luann's asked so
hard when they went to that dinner I
felt like they went to that dinner
because there are the two oh Gees of New
York and it's like the the bee is dead
like we have to make this ring and we're
be best friends to show that like we
were only ever feuding because of
Bethenny like everything was just like
Bethenny Bethenny Bethenny and I even
feel like Aliyah is like she dives
she's Bethenny vibes and so and she's
not the Bethenny that we we had what
she's the Bethenny that we've got and
and I'm I'm so here for her that dinner
with LuAnn and Ramona was so awkward and
like so weird and the way that Ramona
was like conceding so hard to LuAnn
about the room I thought was so weird
but then she did end up giving LuAnn
like the worst room I just thought that
was weird like I get what Ramona was
saying but Ramona is not done like she
knows that that room is the worst room
and the way she like branded it and like
went out of her way they like give it to
the man early on that was just thought
that one thing made actually no sense to
me it really did make no sense because
the room that you're into God I think is
the best room beautiful um and maybe
Ramona gave her into that room because
she wants the best room in the
Berkshires
she's so crafty like that yeah but you
know what they could have done Ramona
Dorinda or LuAnn could have had that
nice room and they could have
potentially and we in the Jack and Jill
I thought that they were in that room
the two twin beds and they totally would
be would have been so happy like behind
I thought that that was a room for two
people too but then also it's like I
don't know if I were staying at Ramona's
and someone gave me like a basement onto
myself as my own bathroom and my own
setup like I'm kind of into that
yeah there's two different types of
people like I love having my own space
but I would hate being away from
everyone and I would hate feeling like
scared in a basement like so but then
there are some people who prioritize
just the fact that she has her own
bathroom over everything else yeah I I
think I might be one of those people I
don't know I'm like what does she really
need her own entrance for it's so weird
she was like you could bring in a man
like that whole room thing or like she
could have put Tinsley and Leah down
there she could with two people yeah
yeah and I'm assuming Sonja staying with
Ramona yeah by the notice house is not I
was just about to say that it's so nice
I know last season people were getting
her shed because it like looks like like
a gravestone encounter it was just
giving her [ __ ] because she said she
redecorated wouldn't this she just
painted an order new furniture but to me
that's decorating she also got new
countertops like she did a full
redecoration when she invited everyone
over last season it wasn't ready but
it's really beautiful
even before I didn't even mean the decor
I just meant like the property that she
has it's on a lake it has a pool it's
huge even before but like her grandma
furniture when her and Mario lived there
I always thought it was a really really
nice
and um Ramona's finances confused me a
lot but she has a huge house in
Southampton and like that's a three
million dollar house yeah I feel like
Ramona it's funny because even though
she's like this New Age reality TV star
she's still like a 63 year old New York
socialite and I feel as though her
priorities like I want a beautiful
Hamptons house and like whatever she
probably took two seasons worth of
payment and was like I'm getting this
house and she sold her New York
apartment it's like you would like she
had a really nice apartment in New York
and a really nice apartment the Hamptons
and she's sold her New York apartment
and like knocked down sighs yeah she
downsized because ivory moved out like
she downsized like she would have
preferred to have a lesser home in the
city and a nicer house mahan I mean I
completely respect that you know it's
like her priorities are still like just
you know house in the Hamptons what is
she in Southampton yeah like she's you
know she's not going to clog no totally
that was mean that first season where
they go to Quogue is so funny so funny
um the whole tattoo saga I love Sonja
but first of all I have two problems
with her in this episode she was being
like a really big [ __ ] stirrer and like
kind of an amine why not like a harmless
fun way like she usually does and I had
a big problem with the interview look
she was sporting because she looked so
weird yeah she looked a beard I think
she's like trying out some new stuff
yeah um and it always like looks weird
at first but then she always does look
great and I really love her though all
the conversation around tattoos was so
weird cuz I actually think this group of
women like and most how I was like are
pretty progressive like it was so
strange it was so strange they're acting
like you know that all these women in
there that they're in their first
marriage has been married forever like
clutching their pearls tattoos it was
really like season one we're going to
Brooklyn you had sex with a pirate I
know totally it was such a rude
conversation it bothered me so much
partially because I just really like Lea
and like I feel defensive of her but
like are you [ __ ] kidding me like
arrested drunk fell in a bush and like
we're over here being mad about a [ __ ]
stamp one that she's acknowledged it's
trashy and is getting removed but it's
like we're really judging people like
anything they're not even judging that
one trashy tattoo they're judging all of
them the cute ones the daughters name
like Chanel it's so weird
I have something crazy to say I liked
her hat I like I liked her hat too
because she was just giving us a little
bit of that like gems Lea intentions
by yeah um my biggest problem this hole
obviously I don't know that she's gonna
be like the fashion icon that we need no
did you see her purse but I don't think
that I'm sorry I don't regard her but
yeah but that is what we need though we
need like I need more of an like a
Bethany attitude which she definitely
hasn't Dorinda said about the end of the
episode like she holds her own but I'm
sorry to Rinda it's really just awful I
have control out of control I mean first
of all okay I get that we're supposed to
feel bad for her cause she's going
through a lot but what she described to
us as a lot I don't really understand
and there's obviously more more to it
like is she having financial troubles
because a flood is very inconvenient but
it's not an excuse for you to become a
bad person no and it's like you it's
it's an inconvenience for sure and it's
a lot to have on your plate but there
has to be more to that like you're not
just gonna start lashing out at everyone
because your house flooded and it seems
like Sonia knows with what what's really
going on because she's very uh
irrationally defending Dorinda yeah and
then we do know that Durand and John
break up so maybe we will get more
insight into what's going on that's
making her so upset I would like to
share and I understood why it's only if
there is something else going on in
sewing and knows it you know Dorinda is
completely in the wrong I understood
Sonjia being like I'm going to have
during this back because like that is
what she needs right now
of course and because Leah does have
tensley's back and Sonja is always a
sympathetic person always but I would
like to share an excerpt from Bryan
moines that I thought was so pertinent
oh I didn't mean his about to end up I
think German does other problem is that
she has been rewarded by the fans for
her not nice behavior we've made clip
clip I'll tell you how I'm doing that
well [ __ ] into catchphrases however
both of these instances was where she
was acting shamefully towards someone
who didn't really deserve it
Dorinda scorestreak is being rewarded so
she has no reason to default to kindness
anymore I think at her heart to Rend is
a good person who always means well but
boy she has a mean streak wider than the
big screen tube television that Ramona
keeps in her basement I'm sorry her
lower level it's true like Dorinda when
we think about like all the things we
think about Dorinda she says horrible
things like Sonja's vagina is the
Holland Tunnel like every time and she
becomes like iconic for it but at the
end of the day I think we forget like
behind all those catchphrases like a
really mean-spirited person yeah
and I've never really regarded her as
like an a mean person but this season
it's just coming out
yeah yeah I totally agree even like
remember when they were in when they
went to Puerto Rico and so my god like
that was the most crazy offense and it
just sort of breeze rolled off the back
awful awful and but that's also season
ten that's the Carroll and Bethany
season that really was a fabulous season
yeah it was so those are my thoughts I
mean it was watching them out to dinner
oh my god made me just I'm like I'm
literally text my friends I'm like when
are we going oh my god it was so hurtful
hurtful Wow and then keeping up with the
kardashians was on very slow and weird
episode back to those seasons where they
have these contrived plots like
obviously that's tough at like the
redhead the Beverly Reid Bev Hill yeah
that was all contrived Khloe and Malika
couldn't even keep a straight face like
and where'd they get those hats they
went from the ice cream to the hotel and
they had hats it was that was dumb but
there was some stuff that was actually
cracking me up like the beginning of the
episode when Kendall and Chloe are out
to dinner and Kris is talking about her
sex life and their faces like I was
laughing out loud and it like it was
just a good episode
I know everyone thinks it was boring and
contrived but that's not that's like
always what the show has been and yet
all these like scandals and crazy things
have happened over the years and so like
we forget that like at the end of the
day when nothing's going on like this is
what they resort to like yeah these fake
plots
I thought the plot of Kris trying to set
up Chloe with those guys from Nick
sporting goods and the guy said the golf
course were so hot I just want to say
the dicks sporting good thing was
totally an ad right you think a hundred
percent hmm do you think that MJ and
Chris peruse the aisles at Dick's
Sporting Goods I don't know but I I mean
like I mean I'm just here for it I wish
Cleo go out with one of those guys the
golf guys were so cute and they were so
nice and that is exactly what Chloe
needs and I know MJ's a toaster because
she's saying that Chloe needs a
businessman but an accountant or a
plumber and it counting or a plumber I
think like an accountant would be
perfect for me a highlight of the whole
episode was seeing Mauricio Umansky at
Scott's listing I know but he was acting
like someone who had never been on
reality TV before like so like overly
hello like maybe he was just like
excited to branch out and now be known
as businessman you know yeah I'm like a
different network I love the scene of
Scott practising hey oh that was his
talking points on Kim
that circle at The Improv oh my god I
would have died Kim is so awkward
she's so awkward she at least she tried
but Scott did a really good job but
kinloch was not in the episode at all
hmm except for the Scott thing maybe she
was like busy with her million dollar
businesses live lady livelihood yes
maybe she was busy getting someone out
of prison I was having just like a hard
time keeping up with this episode it was
just and I hate to say but like Kourtney
does bring that no man no I refused to
admit it like aside from that Beverly
reg Bev Hills Shire Hotel moment I
thought the episode was so cute and just
like back to the old good times you know
just know if Kendall's in an episode
like they've gotten desperate and next
week we have Kylie getting her LASIK eye
surgery so we are getting some Kylie
like I think it's just it's going back
to like what the show is not every
episode can be like Paris great a day
Jordan 3 maybe for like hardcore seasons
with the interest in with Paris like
they'd have like a good run in the last
few years
yeah I knew Cortney stuff last night
it's also fun to just get back to like
the light-hearted family stuff I just
thought it was it was funny I was like I
mean I had a bit of I need a little bit
more okay well I'm just glad it's not
coming from like Kourtney and some clean
Cohn thing like I really would rather
see Scott talk about real estate with
Josh Altman no Jackie of course Josh
Altman is a sociopath
like with his [ __ ] GoPro look Oh like
he was in the [ __ ] UFC or something
yeah I've seen Sophie I was there and
they were talking about Mason like in
the girls it was just like a lot of
cuteness I did feel like weird seeing
Sophia like as a parent not as a parent
but just like as an adult that mother
with kids around and Mason and his
girlfriends were hilarious you did when
your phone number I don't have a phone
how old is he
we went through this but he has a phone
maybe isn't it I pad has an iPad we went
through this yes still does not have a
phone but he does it him an iPad first
school it was fine it was fine those
were my notes litter it was fun it was
fine they're just a pleasure to watch
like they're so stunning and beautiful
stunning and smart and I just love his
family like I can for our toast areas of
the weekend we have decided to assign
the recent episodes of little fires
everywhere on Hulu I haven't I think I
missed the last two weeks I don't know
how many episodes I think it's two but I
heard a lot happens it's available on
Hulu if you haven't watched the series
you can catch up we'll be recapping the
entire season on Monday if you are all
caught up
congratulations if you're in the middle
congratulations I think they get to
catch me too because I was gonna do that
anyway yeah I mean I think that's all we
have make sure to enter our giveaway if
you're looking for some merch gift cards
that's in our Facebook group the morning
toaster if you have something that like
you want to share with us as to why you
want the merchants just want to DM Ison
I mean private message us on Facebook um
feel free to do that if you don't feel
comfortable like sharing with the class
yes thank you guys so much for this what
else do you want merch make sure
together because the next time you see
us on this show those bring merch store
will be closed so that is shot morning
toast calm everything is available get
what you want except for the tie-dye
long-sleeve in medium and large so those
those sizes of that item are flying off
the shelves so if you want something I
would suggest ordering it sooner rather
than later but the merch store does
closed on Sunday night at 9 o'clock
Eastern Time thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning toast the
Millennial morning show where we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube so if you're watching us
on YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcast me down so that Spotify iTunes
stitcher public video I never know
cashbox all the places whoever you
listen to podcast find us the money
doesn't leave a five star review about a
beautiful stunning and smart we are we
hope you guys have a great weekend self
distant social distance and we'll see
you on Monday bye